they claim it's the biggest trade deal
since brexit but the government also
estimate the impact may be small
increasing the size of the UK economy by
just 0.08 in 10 years this is one of the
fastest growing areas in the world
around half of the world's middle class
consumers will be in this block of
countries by the end of the decade it's
a massive opportunity for British
exporters
loosening restrictions and reducing
tariffs has meant this deal seems
universally popular with conservatives
even if labor are tempering their
excitement I do think it's an important
trade deal but the yield is very small
hopefully that will grow over time but
you know the rule in trade is that
you're more likely to trade with your
nearer neighbors more and more often and
so we do need that improved that better
trading relationship with the EU
the UK becomes the 12th member of the
partnership joining Australia Brunei
Canada Chile Japan Malaysia Mexico New
Zealand Peru Singapore and Vietnam the
block agrees to drop almost all tariffs
on goods and the UK government says
membership will boost the UK economy by
1.8 billion pounds in the long run
the deal fits with the UK's foreign
policy focus on the indo-pacific early
this month Rishi sunak unveiled a
nuclear submarine deal with the U.S and
Australia and membership of the cptpp
block now gives the UK a veto on others
joining both China and Taiwan are
looking to join it and you know there
are going to be complexities around the
conversations that the the member states
will have to have regarding both Taiwan
and China looking specifically at
America the reality is the the Biden
Administration currently is much more
inward looking they're not look they're
not having a program now of free trade
agreements
the government insists this deal does
not end the UK's ban on hormone-treated
beef and whilst it will lead to the
relaxation of tariffs on Malaysian palm
oil one major reason for deforestation
in that country why all sources argue by
being in the block the UK is better able
to campaign on environmental issues
after leaving one big trading block
joining another is progress even if the
journey to economic growth is likely to
be a long one Joe Pike Sky News